-Guys,
and I'm serious about this.
Please don't spoil this, okay?
But, if anyone played Wordle
today, don't tell me what it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't tell -- You did play?
Don't tell me.
I want to play Wordle right now.
-Right now?
-Did you do it?
-I didn't do it this morning.
-Me neither.
Did you do it?
-Yeah.
-Alright, you did it.
Alright, so, Higgins,
you can't play.
-Z!
No.
-You ruined it.
So, you know the game Wordle?
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you don't know it, it's some
website you got to go to,
some wordle.uk or something.
You guess the first five
letters, right?
And if you're close,
it gives you a yellow square.
If you're completely correct,
they give you a green square.
-Right.
-But I think
we can play together.
-Okay.
-Right?
-Let's do this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, is my screen --
My screen will go up?
This is my screen,
so I can move the mouse.
There you go right there. Okay.
-Roll the dice, move your mice.
-Alright, here we go.
What's our first word?
What do you normally
go with, Quest?
-I did "title" yesterday
and I got it in three guesses.
-Title.
I usually go with "loved."
-See, you're confident that a
"V" is going to be in this word?
-Oh, that's interesting.
-I always do --
-That's in --
-I always do "arise"...
-Arise.
-...or "adieu."
-Yeah.
-Because that's got a lot of
vowels in it.
-Adieu?
-Mm-hmm.
-Nice.
-Adieu?
Is that a word?
-Yeah.
-Adieu.
-I know ado, A-D-O, but adieu?
-Yeah, like --
-A-D-I --
-I bid you a fond adieu.
-Nice.
-Fond adieu?
-Yeah.
I'm sorry. Fondue.
-Fondue would be a word.
That's too many letters.
It's five letters.
Alright, so, let's --
What are you thinking?
Title, loved, or adieu?
-I like his arise better.
-Do arise.
-Alright, I'm going to do arise.
Alright, here we go.
-It's "R," "S,"
a bunch of vowels.
You should be good.
-Arise.
This is our first word
we're doing.
Here we go.
-Ooh!
Alright! Yes!
Alright, so, it's "A."
We got "A" is definite.
That's a guaranteed letter.
-That's exactly the right place.
-Yes, that's exactly right,
and "E" is somewhere in there.
-Wow, no "R," "I," "S" in it?
-No.
-Wow.
-Alright, so, now --
So it's "A" definitely.
And there's an "E"
in there somewhere.
So it's "A," blank, "E,"
I'm assuming.
"A," "H" -- No.
Achoo?
-I thought the same thing.
-What?
-What do you think?
-But there's no "E" in "achoo."
-The "E" is in -- That's true.
There's no "E" in achoo.
All? All?
App?
Aet?
An?
An sounds like something?
A-N-E?
-Awake?
-No, 'cause the E's
in the wrong spot.
-Higgins, you can't --
-I'm just saying the rules.
I'm not saying you're close.
I'm saying the rule.
You don't want to guess that,
because the "E" --
You'd blow the "E."
-So, words usually end with "D."
-Ahead.
Let's try that.
Ahead.
-[ Imitates buzzer ]
-Oh!
-Hmm!
-So it's definitely the
second-to-last letter.
-Yeah.
-The "E" is definitely
the second-to-last letter.
-Yes, that's correct.
It has to be.
So the "E" is definitely
the second, so --
-With no "R" and no "D" added?
Wow. That's crazy.
-No "D" in there either. Ahead.
So it's
"A," blank, blank, "E," blank.
E-R?
Adhere?
-Nope.
We got a "R" right there
in "arise."
I'm just saying.
The rules of the game.
I'm not cheating.
-I almost want Higgins'
microphone to be turned off,
just because...
-No, he's right.
-We've gotten this far.
No one spoiled it.
-Alright.
-He's right. He's right.
-I know he's right.
He's right. He's right. He's...
Alright, ad -- ad --
-What could follow an "E"
that's not "S," "R," or "D"?
-"T."
-A "P"?
-"T"?
"T"? E-T?
-Phone home.
-I don't think it's E-T.
It's "E..."
-"N."
-"N"?
Oh. Again?
-Ah!
-No.
[ Audience groans ]
-Sorry, sorry. Hey, sorry! Gosh!
-Alright.
Oh, my gosh!
I'm just suggesting something.
What?!
Alright, Quest,
what do you think?
-Ah, damn!
It's too much pressure.
-I know.
-I thought it was going to be
"aware," but it's not, no.
-Awake?
-Awake.
-Mnh-mnh
-No, the "E" has
got to be before the --
It's in the middle.
-Annex.
-Annex?
-Mnh-mnh.
-Geez. That's really tricky.
I mean, what day is today?
Thursday?
Should it be this hard?
-No, it was a hard one.
-This is too hard.
Quest, maybe just stop playing
the drums and just focus.
-Yeah.
-Get your head in the game.
-Okay.
-Come on!
-Annex?
-Judas Priest.
On a Thursday?
[ Laughter ]
Of course not! Annex?!
That's a Sunday word!
-It's cool. It's cool.
-Annex.
-It's cool. I meant --
-It's not cool.
I'm so upset.
-We're progressing right now.
We're good. We're good.
-Okay, okay, okay.
Don't freak out.
[ Laughter ]
-Asked.
-Asked?
I got to zone out.
So, you got --
Look at those letters left.
So...
-"F."
I mean, now I'm
hoping for spoilers.
-Alley!
-Alley?
Oh, yeah,
that feels like a Thursday.
Alley.
[ Drumroll ]
Ooh!
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
-Ashey? Ashey?
No, no, no.
There's an "S" in it.
-Ashey?
-No, no, no.
-Abbey?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, "Downton Abbey."
I feel that way.
I feel that -- It's England.
This thing is U.K. -- wordle.uk.
I think it's "abbey."
-Really?
Okay.
-You don't think it's "abbey"?
-It could be.
I mean, isn't that
a proper noun?
Like, are proper nouns
allowed or...
-Abbey?
-I mean --
-No, it's allowed.
-Let's try abbey.
You guys agree? Abbey?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh, I think
it's really allowed.
[ All cheering ]
♪♪
-Whoo-hoo!
Yeah! Whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
Thank you!